hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's time for our last weekly meet up in
fortnight Battle Royale season 9 our
final chance to check out all the map
changes and hint to future content if
you'd like to win a battle pass watch
the video and guess what will happen
next season up vote your favorites and
I'll give them a battle pass if you're
already up to date with this series jump
to this timecode here but for everyone
else we're going to start from week one
all those weeks ago check the
description if you'd like to skip to any
week in particular
anyway you ready let's do this week 1
after leaving the bunker with hobo teef
ooh new areas of the map were ready for
our attention tilted towers of retail
roll were destroyed in the previous
seasons volcano attack
and now replaced by neon filled
futuristic builds the Megamall and neo
tilted oh look
blimps remember the rune spots back in
2018 well at each of these regions a
drone like air platform appeared
energized by the power of Kevin the cube
oh and the power coming in to neo tilted
there's a power line running all the way
from loot Lake and the vault we unlocked
last season I wonder what will happen
when the power runs out maybe we'll find
out in season 11 oh and a new ways to
get around in season 9 the air streams
kinda like blankness fans the volcano
which caused this Cataclysm is now a
crater a shadow of its former self now a
power plant once again used to energize
the island new technology there seems to
be a theme running through the season as
there's another power source the wind
turbines which sprang up on the high
areas of the map so we have wind
geothermal and alien or supernatural
powers somewhere here too climate change
is real ladies and gentlemen up in junk
Junction the wreckage of the volcano and
everything it destroyed was slowly
gathering here such as the og clock
tower other memories rip the dream small
changes included a wooden fish in the
swamplands area at the north of the map
truckasaurus looks to be a lot happier -
and houses southwest of Megamall had an
upgrade oh and here's where we find that
giant fish which somehow ended up here
it still works by the way yes indeed and
the greatest addition to the new season
is John Wick's house I want fun by too
much but who Jana Reeves anyway John
Wick's house is here and so too is the
Continental the hotel in which he stays
went on assassination missions and
keeping in with the film the basement in
his house has hidden loot bloody genius
another tiny change which could grow
into something is the hut above the farm
it was destroyed by Kevin all those
seasons back but now has begun the
repair process let's see what happens
next
and one last update the giant chair
which became a toboggan is now an
intergalactic ship potentially
foreshadowing space next season we shall
see
[Music]
Oh week two has arrived let's look at
all the map changes the bow there's none
there's none this none at all none
nothing happened in week two see you
next week
things are now beginning to heat up in
week 3 after polar peak was hit by the
volcano late last season we knew
something must be going on here well
this week the ice began to melt the
impact has sunk in and could be a door
something behind there is going to be
shown we shall not know more until next
week but it's bloody exciting isn't it
all the same over in the West a new
house is being built a new construction
using the foundations of the original
house in this location an architect has
decided to do his own thing and damn
that's ugly as hell but you do it fella
Ubu things get even freakier inside as a
shrine to a pizza Pete can be found that
is weird what on earth is happening here
let's check back in future weeks but now
comes the update we really need it the
stone family love story continues last
season rock the Dwayne Johnson and his
fiancee Sharon Stone run into each
others arms and when I say ran I mean
slowly meandered over nine weeks but
they made it all the same
now in season 9 their love has been
consummated and they have a son little
stone Stan the family have a plot of
land to enjoy just above lonely Lodge I
love this family
[Music]
week four what's new this time around
straight back to that stone family and
their new plot of land little stone Stan
has vanished no okay he's only going for
a walk don't panic
he's venturing out into the new worlds
but please PLEASE epic games don't
murder him he means more to me than my
own family at this point anyway if we
look around this area it's likely that
stone Stan will find a pet because
slightly north is a dog on a tree don't
worry he doesn't have a stone taja yeah
I checked and I know I shouldn't have
the stone family maybe the greatest
story ever told but the biggest news of
the week is this big bugger down at
polar peak a freaking eyeball is in the
mountainside basically the melting area
is giving him a way to get out of that
block of ice and get this his eye
follows you it's completely aware of its
surroundings it has to break free at
some points I'll call it now it will
trample straight up the island all the
way to loot Lake by the way I legit did
this for about three houses I officially
have no life also this week the Viking
village takeover of snobby Shores is
finally complete they fought well but
this area is effectively Viking village
from now on
[Music]
holy Sh week five has given us a massive
update to that monster in polar peak
because he's escaped or it's escaped or
she's escaped I'm sorry I'm not sexist
and by the looks of those footsteps it's
Mike Wazowski the monster has not gone
to loot Lake as I expected it's gone for
a swim beelining straight over the snow
leaving footprints behind and into the
ocean now who's gonna stand looking for
it in the sea for hours
oh the noticeable updates this week see
the stone boy and the dog get a little
closer together but come on the hurry up
the suspense is killing me
for dog's sake oh and hot watch it's got
a second layer now from destruction to
restoration and now improvement what is
going to happen next random guesses are
needed
I say it's a clock tower Oh
out of nowhere someone indeed did spot
the monster in the ocean it looks like
he's carrying polar Peaks castle on his
back kind of like Shadow of the Colossus
let's see where he goes next out of
nowhere the modern house in pleasant
park has been destroyed
holy [ __ ] Batman who would do such
a thing
it must be that polar peak monster going
back over to snobby shores we can now
see that the house on the right has
literally been stepped on and smashed to
smithereens so this is the monsters path
so far out of the Ice Mountain over to
the sea back over to snobby shores
through Pleasant Park so he has to be
going to loot Lake right we'll see next
week
week six and yes indeed the monster has
gone all the way to loot Lake and
destroyed an entire building there with
its big-ass footprint as evidence is
that right is the monster invisible or
are these updates supposed to be while
we are asleep I always get confused by
that what's interesting here is that the
electrical cabling running from loot
lake all the way to neo Tilted has been
damaged
so maybe Tilted will have a power cut in
future weeks other areas of the map show
the summer update with beaches filled
with snow cone trucks barbecues
campfires sun beds all that goings but
the best thing of all over scythe beach
balls
everyone gets happier with a little bit
of sunshine I don't know about you but
I'm a son of a beach I said Beach
YouTube don't demonetized me let's go
back to the hut to see what's going on
oh wow it has three storeys I want my
clock tower
come on clock tower I have faith in you
let's check up on this next week and the
last update in week six let's go back
over to rock the Dwayne Johnson and his
family they continue to plant seeds on
their plot of land
one day this shall grow into a mighty
Beanstalk but where the heck is the kid
as he found that dog yet oho check this
out he does crazy parkour acrobatics now
this boy is becoming a man and the dog
we saw last time urinating on a tree
he's now humping a tree come on a big
what are you doing
hang on what's the dog gonna do when he
meets the boy later in the story I
thought this was a child-friendly video
game oh and just as I was uploading this
thing appeared miss not be shows it's
confirmed to be a fault by challenge
[Music]
week 7 has arrived with a few tasty
updates to the map first things first
this ducks now yeah it's legit once
again a summer update for the two weeks
of summer two weeks I'd have called it
the fortnight fortnight you suck I will
stop these terrible puns what
you start using coded amaru all right
the biggest update this week is linked
to the main storyline check out the old
volcano the power plant has transformed
into this looking at the design I reckon
this is humanity's way of fighting the
polar peak monster
have you seen Pacific Rim a hulking
great mech takes on a freaky Godzilla
like beast time for us to witness that
in the live event in fortnight I can't
wait over to the family made of stone it
looks like the parents are enjoying a
little time away from their little brat
of a son Dwayne the rock Johnson is
straight up giving Sharon Stone the eyes
the come to bed eyes okay maybe not he's
just relaxing after planting his crops
his son Kid Rock is busting this pose
can't be topped my friend
live your dreams he's actually spotted
something though another plant by the
looks of it maybe he's going to pick it
up for his parents and take it back home
I said a few weeks ago that I want a
magic Beanstalk here could it happen
what do you think here's my guess the
boy falls and the dog catches him but
where the heck is the dog anyway oh
there he is she by a true sitting
sitting by a tree sorry will their paths
ever cross let's check back next week
[Music]
it's week eight what could have
developed in the fog knife world well
let's start with what watch nothing no
difference just the same see you next
week back to the family mama has spotted
something holy balls Kid Rock is trying
to grab the flower from last week chill
out mama cuz Kid Rock is made of strong
stuff
you could say he's a rock in situations
like this he's bolder than most kids so
will the dog save Kid Rock
he's currently sniffing around this area
by an outdoor toilet more on the rock
family next week and now for the big one
it's here we look to be right about a
huge mech coming to fort night the first
part has arrived at the power plant two
feet and half a leg this may take longer
than we thought but slowly and surely
over the coming days we will see this
built upon so keep an eye on this area
prepare the island for annihilation by
the way during the live event I
challenge you to land on top of the
beasts while they are fighting can you
do it send me a screenshot if you can
please and finally the next crossover
event looks to have started over at the
mega mall if you didn't know the ice
cream parlor in mega mall scoops ahoy is
in fact a place found in the series
stranger things not only has the venue
given as ice creams to munch on it has
also given us these held doors they acts
like portals just like the ones in
whaling woods a few seasons back I found
six so far so have a look around and see
if you can spot any more instantly
transport from one side of the mega mall
to the other looks like exciting times
ahead and stranger things to come
week 9 has landed and the story
continues jumping back over to the
volcano and throughout the week the
robot continued to build
he now has a torso check out that rack
wha
looking at the fort bites we can expect
a bear head to be added like a
mechanical Colonel team leader so hang
on is this robot going to be pink come
on I pick do this for me please real men
wear pink nope there seems to be
electronic advertisement
at various places on the map they first
show a warning sign before they look
like an old world war 2 motivational
image in posters for example this image
is taken from the we can do it poster
designed to motivate female workers
during the war these will likely be used
to show a countdown to the event but
they will also give us clues about the
future I'm going to keep my best theory
to myself for the time being until I've
made the season 10 video but look at
what is being said duck and hover get to
high ground could the entire island be
at risk during the event I hope so what
areas of the map are you happy to lose
yeah nothing nothing nothing changed
again maybe next week
I did make ballsack mana to replace it
but that was pretty immature move on
over to the stone family rock the Dwayne
Johnson Sharon Stone and Kid Rock oh no
it happened Kid Rock is about to die
he's going to fall on top of the dog by
the looks of it and what are his parents
doing simply stood there like statues
got to admit the characterization in
that mama rockin looks brilliant legit
can tell her son's peril is hitting her
heart what will happen next I think the
dog will save him what do you say
finally this week it has become possible
to unlock different color schemes for
the unlockable character singularity
what's really interesting though is the
theme of each skin the kernel team
leader rex der burger drift pizza pit
could singularity be pulling all these
characters together before taking
control of that mech over there sounds
good to me
[Music]
it's finally here the final week of
season 9 week 10
our final Meetup and what a week it's
been so let's start with the biggest
thing of all the hut has a new layer
four blocks high now the future really
is here look at this marvel of
engineering oh okay I get it you don't
really care about hood watch so here's
the next biggest thing of the week the
robot factory went into overdrive both
arms have been built and we're now
simply waiting for the helmet holy balls
look at that it here overnight the mech
was finished take that power rangers
fortnight's Megazord is here taking the
head of the colonel team leader the arms
of rex and drift and the legs of pizza
pit and the derp burger everything
brought together by our fearless leader
singularity who will take control of the
Megazord and fight the circling beast
this Saturday all it needs now is the
infinity sword for this to be complete
how great does that look by the way GG
for my design team great work and you
know it's going to be in Toys R Us this
Christmas there's only one thing we can
finish on for season ten story and map
updates it's back to the Stone family
last week we saw Kid Rock in peril he
was moments away from dropping to his
death this week the panic looks to be
over the dog has indeed come to his
rescue and is pulling him to safety
you're my hero stone dog in fact we need
a name for the dog please help me out
what shall we call this mutt oh and
there's also another dog here but I
think this is just a glitch I think this
is the original dog I don't think this
two of them now but there could be we'll
find out next season so there we have it
from the icecap cracking to the final
battle of season 10 this weekend this
has been a great season for storytelling
and map updates thank you so much for
watching this series and a special shout
out to those who used code atom arrow in
the shop I should be working on
something completely different today but
that support helped me prioritize things
like this so thank you it really means a
lot to me so if you want to win the
battle puss for season 10 have a guess
what will happen if you are funny or if
you're a voted a lot I'll send you one
for free I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure I'll see
you after the battle